thank you Ted will utility scam
Awareness Day is coming up on Wednesday
which is a good opportunity to talk
about scams and what tactics to keep an
eye out for so Envy energy the sponsors
of today's segment are here to help
joining us is the director of corporate
Communications Jennifer sure Jennifer
thank you so much for being here oh
thank you for having us so let's get
right into it what are some of the most
common scams that you see or that we
should keep an eye out for the most
common thing is having someone falsely
representing themselves as in the energy
calling or emailing our customers and
threatening immediate disconnection if
immediate payment is not made and you
see the spike of these scams during the
holidays why is that well people really
are busy they're distracted by the
holiday season maybe they're doing a
little more shopping they're not paying
quite as close attention to their in the
energy account so it's a lot easier to
believe some of the deceptive claims
they may make about your account so what
should some of your customers out there
keep in mind things that Envy energy
would never do which might be kind of a
red flag to to realize okay maybe this
is is a scam and not something real yeah
there are a few things so first is we
would never call you and demand
immediate payment and threaten immediate
disconnection customers who are at risk
of disconnection are going to get a
10-day notice on their bill and a
48-hour notice in the mail secondly a
lot of these scammers like I said as
part of that demanding immediate payment
they want to payment via Zell or venmo
or a Green Dot card we don't take
payment that way so so those are
definitely red flags if someone's
calling you and making those claims and
are there sometimes false phone numbers
or kind of fake email address or things
like that yeah the scammers are very
sophisticated the number the caller ID
is going to look like an NV Energy
number it'll say in the energy if you
happen to get a voicemail from them and
call them back their voicemail system
the ivr system is going to look like in
the energies but I think just the
important thing to remember is like
we're never going to call you and demand
immediate immediate payment for
immediate disconnection well I am really
glad we're talking about this because we
all do it and you see these numbers pop
up or emails you don't know what to
believe if it's real or not especially
if it's coming from a number that looks
like it's Envy energy you can't help but
think that what is your advice to people
who might be a target of these spams
what should they do so if you're getting
a call and you do have and you wonder
because like I said they're very
sophisticated you know take a breath and
listen to them but if you have any
doubts before you make any payment or
make any move call in the energy go to
your my account and you can see the
status of your payment you know even to
be prepared sign up for alerts you'll
always have an update on where you are
with your account balance your energy
usage if a payment's been made so I if
you hang up if you don't believe them
and if you are in doubt give us a call
well that's really helpful to set up
those alerts because a lot of times
you're wondering is it worth it am I
going to get bombarded and it's it's
definitely worth it especially during
the holidays and times like these and
you mentioned really quickly it's
helpful to access your online account
you can kind of turn to that for
anything right absolutely going to my
account seeing your when your last
payment was made what your account
status is you'll go there first well
thank you so much for breaking this all
down really important things to keep in
mind thank you to NB energy for
sponsoring the segment for more
information it's all on your screen
visit nvenergy.com forward slash cans
we'll be right back